remember when we talked about Donald
Trump's embarrassing speech at the NATO
summit in Brussels Belgium a couple of
weeks ago Trump made these totally
arbitrary claims about NATO States not
paying their fair share in terms of
their contributions to NATO demanding
that other countries expand their
military budgets he refused to affirm
article 5 of the NATO Charter which says
that an attack on one NATO country is
considered an attack on all NATO
countries and we already knew that NATO
members were sort of baffled by this but
we've now learned that Donald Trump also
bewildered and surprised our own
national security officials when he made
those comments in Brussels five sources
with direct knowledge of what happened
said that National Security Adviser HR
McMaster and defense secretary Jim
mattis as well as Secretary of State
rectal arson all wanted and were
expecting Donald Trump to show up and
show support for article 5 in his speech
and they were blindsided by what Donald
Trump actually said they worked with
Trump to prepare him in support to
support NATO in that speech they
expected him to support article 5 in
that speech and a day before the speech
a White House aide even told the New
York Times oh yeah Trump's going to
support article 5 in the speech somehow
by the time of the speech Trump instead
ended up showing disdain for the
institution of NATO and according to
sources of involved in the reporting of
the story Trump made the last-minute
change without consulting or even
telling any of his advisors one of the
sources said quote they didn't know it
had been removed it was only upon
delivery
apparently mattis McMaster and Tillerson
who I refer to as the adults in the room
they were trying to get a copy of the
speech right beforehand they got it and
they saw the article 5 thing is gone
from the speech and then it was too late
Donald Trump had changed his mind and as
you know it seems that whatever someone
says to Donald Trump five minutes before
the speech is sort of what sticks and
what he ends up saying this is actually
this is a national security issue and I
know that cobb feffy is funnier and it
makes more headlines you're talking
about a president that is not in
think with the people at the top in
terms of ensuring the security of our
country they're bewildered and
blindsided by what the president is
saying on the national stage I think it
would help if he paid attention to those
daily press briefing for national
security but you know Republicans loved
his speech to NATO because it showed
independence giving the middle finger to
Europe yep I guess this is independent
as well he's not even listening to his
own national security team that's the
problem with this because rational
people like like everybody in our
audience that isn't a you know on the on
the opposite side and you Pat and me we
see this as erratic and haphazard and
dangerous that's not how a lot of
trumpets are going to see it they're
going to see this and think great this
shows that Donald Trump is independent
he thinks for himself he tells it like
it is he won't be influenced by
so-called experts really this just shows
the level of dysfunction in the
administration and even if Donald Trump
wanted to do this and wanted to defy the
advice of his advisers who were more
qualified than him the least he can do
is at least inform them that he's going
to do this tell them a you were going to
disagree on this instead of switching
things around on the fly which is it
there's no upside to doing that and let
me know if I'm getting too
conspiratorial here but obviously the
speech to NATO played well into Russia's
hand because they know that United
States wouldn't necessarily act if one
of the NATO members was attacked right
so is it perhaps possible that because
HR McMaster and general mattis aren't
really involved in the Russia scandal
there's really no direct connection to
them at this point well that's why he'd
want to keep them out of the loop
without getting proactively
conspiratorial there's no doubt that
Trump would be much more in line with
disgraced former national security
adviser Michael Flynn in terms of his
stance on me I think Michael Flynn would
have known I think you're absolutely
right Lynn would have proposed that this
is what Trump says and it's yet another
way in which Russia is going to sort of
like what Donald Trump is doing which
we've been talking about as well I don't
think it's to conspirator okay go in
that direction now